bonjour le caviar comment vas-tu ma
petite hirondelle tient elle ne m'a pas
répondu
évidemment les plus durs sont ni ça
alors elle quand elle trouve dans un
arbre
les orcades ya les lanka bien ouais tu
vous n'avez pas voulu acadia non bon
allez peut-être dans l'autre arbres là
les arcadiens vous n'avez perdu mon
hirondelles mercadier c'était
épouvantable
elle n'est plus le jardin il faut faire
quelque chose
je vais aller téléphoner amerloques
formelle ça c'est le plus grand
détective du monde
j'ai pas son numéro ça c'est une
catastrophe
françois françois plus vite et bien qu'y
a t'il encore casimir pour la critique
comme ça si tu savais elle a disparu
mais non mais non julie n'a pas disparu
regarde elle arrive derrière toi moi
enfin c'est par de jolies que je parle
qu'est-ce que tu achetais tangriev une
force et c'est épouvantable elle a
disparu
ah bon qui ne l'êtes pas si c'est le let
je les rencontrais tout à l'heure bon
mais vous êtes incroyables tous les deux
m'enfin cutone ctt casimir jeu n'est pas
très clair lors des explications roman
mais c'est lumineux
ouvrez vos yeux regardez les occasions
n'est plus l'enfant n'y a
mais steam il n'est sûrement pas bien
loin
or j'ai cherché partout où j'allais
appeler elle n'est pas dans le jardin
qu'il aimait tant a ajouté irene dunne
enfin j'ai une idée bien oui on va
téléphoner amerloques folle maïs tua son
numéro non casimir je n'ai pas son
numéro mais j'ai mieux j'ai mieux je les
rencontre et il était justement avec le
let
avant elle prime avait cherché alors que
pascal soit tu crois que nous chez
merlotte folle où ça va c'est à dire toi
va trouver léocadia mais évidemment
julie puisque moi je sais où elle se
trouve depuis comment ça dépasse que j'y
réfléchisse un petit peu et six jeunes
avaient fait autant et bien dussault
également emploie encore la dépêche toi
oui j'y vais j'y vais qu'est ce qui les
force à françois enfin mélo monsieur
mais rock falls
il est même supérieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mademoiselle julie je donne le judo à
vous bonjour monsieur mais halak face à
eux de yudu monsieur trésigny c'est ce
qu'ils lisent ils te demandent comment
tu vas en anglais très mal mais sur le
match très mal je les ai perdus qui que
quoi où comment un disparu
françois ne nous a pas mis au courant no
j'ai perdu les anta dia ma petite
hirondelle haut mais je veux essayer de
guinée lui et c'est unis que me je vais
vous montrer son iphone à peine il est
très fort voici saunier mais c'était un
très joli travail artisanal c'est de la
terre d'attaché voulez vous que je vous
la décrivez là prennent pas la peine je
la vois tout noir avec peut-être le
ventre bulent hills est au seuil est le
salut sien je les trouvais déjà fort les
enfants venez vite venez vite j'ai
besoin de vous monsieur 15eme vous savez
ce qu'est un oiseau migrateur enrôlement
je sais très bien en oiseaux migrateurs
c'est un oiseau qui a des petites pattes
et qui ne peuvent se gratter que la
moitié du d'eau migrateurs
c'est sympa du tout mais j'aime beaucoup
votre humour les infestations vous
connaissez des oiseaux migrateurs alors
par exemple la shiden qu'est ce que
c'est un oiseau migrateur qui voyage
c'est un oiseau qui voyagent pourquoi
voyage tylski ce soit il va dire
show très bonnes réponses lorsqu'arrive
l'automne le froid commence à arriver
il s'envole vers des régions plus
chaudes il reviendra au printemps
tenez regardez quel est cet oiseau
migrateur
non c'est une loi une oie sauvage et
celui ci très bien c'était un caennais
d'un hippopotame médiateur ça existe bon
j'aimerais beaucoup vous tous c'est quel
signal c'est un pigeon mais c'est un
pigeon l'ami louis vous aviez d'ailleurs
c'est une cigogne et enfin et bien
casimir je suis même assez léocadia va
maintenant moussa messieurs 15 min
regarder le calendrier
en france c'est le début du plus tôt et
voilà elle est partie en france soir ses
amis moi alors je comprends pas elle
reviendra ici à l'automne quand il fait
chaud sur la wii rouge je ne sais pas
comment vous remercier monsieur pharnext
et bien en appelant chaque fois que vous
avez une énigme très difficile à relever
je vous aime beaucoup monsieur casimir
ainsi que vous mademoiselle julie au
revoir les enfants mais si balbo
baragnon il est vraiment charmant
il est même supérieur eurociné rommel
qu'est-ce que je suis le plus grand
détective d'humour